to me this is the story of a man who's
on a jock and essentially it was chased
down by people who thought they were
being vigilantes and due to their own
racial bias that was they killed I know
a lot of you wanted us to cover it
personally when I first came to me I
don't know what it is about these
stories I just I find them so so
exhausting like every time I read them I
just feel like I just feel so tired
whenever I see one of these and it's
hard because you understand that apathy
and inaction and these kind of scenarios
does us more harm but it's hard not to
be discouraged when it comes to this
case now some of you might say look at
the pressing charges this is good news
but what I'm really bothered by is that
the only reason that this is being
brought up and this is being brought up
on charges because because the army
because of the video then press charges
they press charges not because they
thought a video but because we thought a
video well they had the video for months
yes right but once it got leaked to us
and it was outraged you know being on
outrage like you're gonna talk talking
everything's what's gonna happen you
gonna go down this chiz you're gonna be
posting and stuff like that retweeting
instagramming you're gonna put some
stuff on on Facebook what are they gonna
do [ __ ] now I know cuz it's the outrage
that did that the fact that they did he
pushed it it's out Rachel nothing else
so what you're saying now you're big on
outrage I'm not big on it but I'm just
like you said tired like yeah big on it
this this isn't tenable justice should
be served but it shouldn't be served on
the basis of everyone getting on their
social medias and screaming at the top
of lungs
we shouldn't have to watch videos of
people being gunned down and and
traumatizing ourselves so that people
can take action that's our that are
adequate but that's absurd to me that we
have to constantly get on this stuff and
take in all these criminal cases all the
time in order for things to start moving
that's ridiculous
and you know what people talk about
while systemic isms aren't real there's
no such thing as systemic this is a
perfect case talking about people
basically covering for each other
because they work together you're
talking about people ignoring the letter
of the law oh you know what that's my
homie he could and it was just like that
I'm gonna retire myself from the whole
thing move away but just know that you
know what I'm gonna move away but I've
had this letter for you right and this
be sad on this they sat on this for
months they sat on this for months and
it just comes to that old thing where
it's just like how many times does this
happen without video the only reason
this is out is because the third person
who's chasing who was the neighbor
decided to be a goofball and recorded
and it had criminate adem self that's
the only reason they had to truly [ __ ]
up for us to know that they [ __ ] up
because if there was no video let me say
that again they had to really [ __ ] up
for us to know that they [ __ ] up
otherwise every other time it happens
every other time that someone's a little
bit smarter and knows how to do it a
little bit better they get away with it
and and it's frustrating because then
you start to cycle through your own
lived experiences where you know bad
[ __ ] happen and you can't do nothing
about it because there's no cameras
present and no one is there and no one's
gonna believe it's you have to move on
but it's just like oh we believe in this
one and it's frustrating because there's
footage and there's almost very little
as being done but imagine every single
time there's no cameras every time they
turn off their body cams and we're
departments where they don't have it
this happens way more than you guys
think when everybody said you know what
we're gonna put body cams on the cops
and the cops said you know what no we're
not putting body cams on why why does it
bother you so much that again why are
you doing your job when you know there's
been [ __ ] you're like no there's not
been fuck-ups okay we're gonna put a cab
no no cam why do you get so aggressive
when I'm filming something that I'm
allowed to do but speak of it in another
point again
the same thing would outraged I was not
so big on having an owning a gun I
didn't understand why would you need a
gun why would you have a gun
would you legally mini a gun a handgun
on you open carry now I get it if I was
a citizen a citizen of the state and I'm
black minute I'm 18 mmm I would get a
gun that's for sure the whole fact the
whole family would be back in hmm the
whole family because I can't count on
the system the system ain't got my back
I can't be nothing about that I gotta
protect myself hmm well listen when the
justice system ignores your crimes
because you used to work at a department
or your son used to be an investigator
or your father used to work at the DA's
office
to me that's indication of a problem
absolutely I understand all the people
that are advocating for protecting
yourself hmm I get it these stories
shouldn't make it to social media they
shouldn't they should be handled
appropriately through the judicial
system and we want to believe but we
don't it's why we see the video we see
nothing's happening it's like oh this
[ __ ] again it should have been from the
from this up it should have been another
the police believe the apartment should
handle this and I don't want to nobody I
know this I don't want to see nobody
riding well you ran towards the boo-boo
according to their own testimony meaning
the to the father and the son
they say that they chased them they say
that they almost stopped him then he ran
the other direction and they ran to cut
him off so he wasn't running towards
them they were waiting in amp there was
one he was one behind and one in front
like where do you want the person to go
well then why did he get an altercation
someone's chasing you with guns telling
you to stop you don't know who they are
they say they want to arrest you you've
never met these people you're just gonna
go in their car you're not the Pilar you
are what you done we just want to talk
to you why do you have your guns with
you am I supposed to trust you you've
been chasing me down with cars yelling I
mean who knows good they [ __ ] saying
I don't know [ __ ] man nah no no no
that's goofy B that's crazy to me that's
crazy that's crazy I find these videos
time I didn't want to do this one
but I did in the Dave you don't say
nothing then you can't expect change you
know it's one thing to be you know stoic
and to kind of reserved your emotions
and try to just control what you can
control maybe we don't have much control
but I think without engaging in public
discourse not talking about these things
we can't hope for them to change without
bringing light to the effect authorities
and justices you can't hope for the
system to change so I don't think we can
turn a blind eye to these kind of things
even if it makes us uncomfortable even
if it is a [ __ ] tour to have to talk
about and it's so goddamn taxing you
have to if you want things to change it
has to be discussed we can't sweep it
under the rug because this is the
standard the standard won't change
unless it's discussed
unless it's constantly brought to light
change is gradual there have been slight
progress but not enough and this is
another indication of the fact that we
haven't moved that needle far enough and
not over so we still need to talk about
it unfortunately yeah even though you're
like I can't believe in 2001 and 2020
the date doesn't mean anything to be
honest with you we still haven't talked
about it we still have to be here in
front of this camera talking to you
about this and the outrage that habits
yeah unfortunately fortunately so yeah I
was listening to 20-20-20 lynching 2.0
that's it that was a little old mob son
a father the neighbor let's take them
down cuz it needs something wrong yeah
so we wanna know your thoughts what do
you guys think about this story how do
you guys feel about it what do you guys
think about you know the judicial system
do you guys have faith in it do you not
we want to hear your thoughts let us
know
[Music]
so I'm gonna tell you guys so
essentially man was shot and killed in
Georgia approximately two months ago
back in February and so the details of
the case were a little hazy to the
public until recently but essentially
what ended up happening was a mod
according to the family was jogging when
he was approached by two cars one
containing a father and a son with guns
and then another car that was behind it
when that happened a mod ran the other
way the car circled around cut him off
at a different point was waiting for him
there and then there was a second car
which was behind a mod following him so
they kind of like had him on both ends
then there's a struggle that ensued when
the son started having an altercation
with the mod and basically the shotgun
he fired it at Ahmad during the struggle
killing him at that point basically what
the father the son claim is that there
have been a string of break-ins and that
the father had seen Ahmad ass or one of
the house casing it out so he suspected
it was a mod so I'm at night said he fit
the same description when he saw him the
next day jogging when he saw him the
next time jogging and so he's like ask
the same guy who I saw
he's been peering in windows we think
he's suspicious they call banwen this
case is super complicated I think why
it's complicated is because there's a
lot of moving parts and to kind of wrap
your head around everything's a little
bit tough but essentially when the
police arrived they took the witness
testimonies they basically said this was
self-defense he attacked us we were
trying to perform a citizen's arrest and
so therefore this is legal okay they
that's what they claim
now the first prosecutor came on
basically had to recuse themselves
because there was conflict of interest
considering that I believe one of them
was a retired private detective one is a
private investigator one is a retired
cop yeah detective yeah yeah the one
worked with some work that the DA's
office
so the first prosecutor recused
themselves the second one also did the
same thing due to conflict of interest
but they actually wrote a letter saying
this
self-defense these people were
performing citizen's arrest and the
altercation ensued as a resulted
self-defense problem with that is that
they never saw a mod in the process of a
crime or they weren't witness to
anything like that so you can't perform
a citizen's arrest and then claim
self-defense in that scenario because
you actually have to witness and that is
very clear in what if then the rest is
right so the third prosecutor came on
and things kind of moved really really
slow for a couple months and then the
video was uploaded anonymously to the
Internet which caused a firestorm and at
which point once it was uploaded to the
Internet and caused a firestorm this the
prosecutor decided to put it to a grand
jury to do a retirement if there's going
if they're going to indict to be clear a
prosecutor can't press charges right
away from wants to but they put it to a
grand jury to determine if there's
enough evidence to push it towards and
I'm not gonna show the video of the
because to me was pretty I don't know I
don't like to use the word triggering
but it's pretty much the only one I can
think of when I saw it I was it [ __ ]
can't watch this but it's not gonna help
anything
yeah probably had seen the video and if
you have it you don't have to and if you
want to you can find it it's not
difficult to find to me I don't want to
watch it again
it's just tiring